Matthews working on Gawker he blocked a
seven-foot Center shot thinking
two-for-one no crib father gonna lift
the sheet that's really quickly
[Applause]
Joseph will defend watch
[Applause]
the path by Chris Paul and aron baynes
complete click welcome to your Kodak
moment my friend I mean what a dime here
by Chris Paul but it's all about Blake
really knocked away still five to shoot
on the drive
Rose happenin top chakra Paul didn't
have a lot of options there
tough tough competitive it's over three
contestant hands stutter step freeze
move Danny Green
welcome to your Kodak moment my friends
here the rebound and they do
[Applause]
on one leg he's trying to will this shot
in takes a step back and just knocks it
down
Game seven one-point game
the winner will move on to the second
round of TNT
[Applause]
welcome back to LA where Chris Paul says
this is my house if you're San Antonio
man what two better defenders could you
have the green and Duncan right there
the presence of mind the gather his
stuff you see he's living he's hurt he
can't even explode off of that leg but
he does wheels the ball in Chris Paul
knocking it down one point zero seconds
left on the clock
Griffin looks into the frontcourt
[Music]
[Applause]
slippers get three it appears
join a nun 38 quarters
that was his loans but met cp3 with the
threat shot clock is at 1:00 Paul he hid
that from thinking he's Paul that long
distance three taken away that's a mini
Chris Paul Tom that's a mini done well
they find him ahead of the pack he
hadn't recovered from the layup the
other end look I've never seen Chris
dunk like that round here and it has
been a foundation for him and for his
bank account this quarter
there's the take away by Paul tsipras
running out three on ones it might be
fun
once again Chris disguised it
beautifully he really made that look
like he was gonna shoot it kind of faked
me around the back then he looks like
he's going to the goal huh and then just
throws it backwards that takes a lot of
faith like is he heard footsteps
he knew he was coming by an all-star
kind of a running jump shot
I don't seconds first quarter here's
Paul on the boom puts it off the
backboard foot Davis and 17 assists in
90 minutes against the Clipper great
ball handling by Paul a basket and the
foul cp3 with a dazzling dribbling job
[Music]
in Cleveland why not
teen seconds of period Chris Paul
absolutely finish this off a remarkable
period of play gets the ball off just
barely in time
[Applause]
1.8 seconds to go the game is ha
give him credit because he doesn't panic
at all doesn't move his feet doesn't
flinch I mean who cares about the
magnitude of the moment is it to JJ JJ
with a great bacon than the pump fake
and look at that that's like a practice
3-ball I look at the bench react yeah
threes he then got propelled into a
starting lineup with their injuries for
the jam now hey
that is what clipper basketball is all
about Blake Griffin
back to ball with two with one from
midcourt Berkeley
it was uphill all the way the LA
Clippers ramble done
come on strong here at the end of the
period to make it a three-point game
this ball his first field goal of the
game when Phil Jackson came in 99 2000
Shaq myself Toby we have been here since
1996
Ginobli boys tickets with the ground
running didn't with that Jam dau
Ginobili you know I always hear people
say you know well of course you can win
the triangle with with Mike and Scotty
and Shaq and Kobe booked the triangle
definitely definitely the head Chris
Paul
motor into the frontcourt pull up to
around three ball Chris ball house going
the Lakers 37 to 16 in the second period
of play whoa
[Applause]
[Applause]
miraculously put down my huge Clippers
three do you feel Paul might have
initiated the contact there true that to
the crowd feels here at Vivid Sparta
marina we saw you have diao Hill and an
Ingles three guys who can really pass
the best of Chris Paul David James
capers the official says it's good and
he took the hit risk that's why we told
you now remember he's accepting who's
accepting the role of being a score
first we know he stole averaging ten
assists in this series but Jordans got
11 points and we eight rebounds the
steal a two-on-one with Crawford back to
Crawford and maybe that gets Jamal
Crawford going a little bit see that's
how you love to see a two-on-one flare
when Dettol right on them and then here
beautiful anticipation for the skip
Michael Carter Williams on the drive is
looking for the contact and couldn't
finish follow for three yes the buzzer
cp3 for three and it's a team because
you had to score or get to the foul line
otherwise there's the fast break and a
three in your face
look at all that space he's got to
operate
[Applause]
boy one foots on the brake Kubla goes
body kisses it off the grabs
what a brilliant old school booze my
crew scars look at that face in the
paint that he has to operate Gerald's
read in the strong side corner the rest
of the Rockets over on the left side
given one of the best isolation players
in the NBA
plenty of room to operate and Trevor
Ariza on the side and that that Gerald
Green who is signed a couple of days ago
who has been terrific they get the run
by Chris Paul i deceptive moved
first up Golden State well if here's
Jordan Ville obviously this is part of
the game plan on the switching in shot
clock winding down the second quarter
here comes Paul look at this I mean he
played last night stopping on a dime
[Applause]
[ __ ] again fellas look at the space
first pause just makes a very difficult
shot and one has got a chance for a
three-point play high off the glass to
go special players you don't want them
with the ball that minification
do you normally say salt of the earth
cp3 stop it now you've got Chris Paul
that is not right I mean that's
something you would see on the Rucker
League and if your zoo box see if
someone else got to take Chris Paul off
the air right here Paul's done for the
night not done career
[Music]
the Raptors have dropped all right this
right top look at this I mean he's all
over the board
oh he bringing rain is bringing
look at this dancing with the basketball
I don't care if you call it glass or not
P check for cp3
[Applause]
fake it to you and then wait for you to
come back to me hitting on man wide open
in the corner the handles of Chris Paul
[Applause]
at 59 and this Paul going into the body
of stuff curry able to grab those
offensive long rebound
you can play great defense and they're
just times where offensively the prayer
get in bottles exit for the second
quarter got it right back with 2/10 of a
second remaining
[Applause]
Taal lets it fly and ten in the third
quarter with confidence he let it fly
Euston up five heading to the pool
seconds ago
Dallas looking for the wind Brunson got
it up it was blocked Chris Paul with the
block at the buzzer and the rocket
survived in win in Dallas 94 93 Wow
Luka dodging guys all over him and watch
Chris Paul with the defensive play of
the game we got to play defense to win
Chris Paul knows that Brunson has a
chance but wow what a defensive block by
Chris Paul
[Music]
Tommy Chris Paul threw it up from well
beyond Mid Continent within D Anderson
here's Chris Paul from El Segundo
60-footer at the buzzer off the glass
component cauley-stein he want he's
taken the shot that's way off in the
Thunder halftime here with under five
seconds Paul double-teamed heaves it
from half court
he got it to go sign it for Wow he just
did that as though I'm just you know
what I just made it three before I know
I'm further out
my foots on the half-court line but
check this out it's good here's Paul
with four seconds left two or three cuz
he knows it's a two for one and then he
waved a knee low Gallinari down so I've
got the matchup I want gets Paul Millsap
reacting to the cross than the between
some legs come on